vous rappelez-vous du personnage du sans
visage dans le film Le voyage de Chihiro
le chaoshi cette ectoplasme ambigu de
l'oeuvre d'ayaomiyazaki a probablement
marqué tous les enfants des années 90
par son design calme et inquiétant sa
voix chevrotante et surtout sa capacité
à générer des pépites d'or dans le film
dans le cas vous ne l'auriez pas vu cet
étrange créature qui s'infiltre dans
l'établissement de bain fantastique ou
se déroule l'intrigue va corrompre 1
tous les protagonistes de l'histoire en
leur offrant des petites pépites d'or ce
qui va lui permettre petit à petit de
s'imposer comme le souverain vénéré du
complexe hôtelier les pépites d'or n'ont
pas de valeur en elle-même par leur
utilité mais c'est bien la valeur qu'on
leur prête du fait de leur Arte supposée
qui en fait des biens désirables et
confère à leur propriétaire un pouvoir
symbolique sur les autres c'est ce qu'on
a vu dans la première partie de cette
série sur l'industrie du diamant vous
n'avez pas besoin d'avoir vu le premier
épisode pour voir celui-ci mais si
jamais vous pouvez cliquer ici pour
aller regarder avant en effet les objets
précieux que ce soit des pépites d'or
des diamants ou des vêtements de luxe
confère une forme de pouvoir à celui qui
les possède et c'est bien pour ça que le
sans visage est une figure qui passionne
l'idée de pouvoir fabriquer une petite
pépites à l'infini étant quelque sorte
le degré ultime de la richesse la plus
haute strate de domination sur le reste
de l'humanité mais cette idée de pouvoir
créer du précieux à partir de rien les
humains n'ont pas vraiment attendu
Miyazaki pour la développer les origines
de l'alchimie discipline qui
prétendaient pouvoir transformer des
métaux villes comme le plomb en métaux
précieux comme l'or remonte jusqu'à la
Chine du 4e siècle avant Jésus-Christ
avec des équivalents qui parviennent
l'histoire de nombreuses civilisations
des antiquités indiennes égyptiennes
mésopotamiennes ou grecques jusqu'à
l'époque que nous connaissons évidemment
mieux des alchimistes européens du
Moyen-Âge pour tout vous dire même Isaac
Newton a passé quelques années de sa vie
à étudier l'alchimie mais ça on va y
revenir heureusement ces croyances un
peu bancales vont bientôt laisser la
place à la chimie que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui notamment grâce aux travaux
d'Antoine Lavoisier un français dont
vous avez sûrement déjà entendu le nom
puisqu'il est tout simplement considéré
comme le père de la discipline alors
certes Antoine Lavoisier ne croyait plus
qu'on puisse transformer du plomb en or
mais cela ne veut pas dire que ce film
ou Polymat ne se rêvait pas en Bernard
Arnault sans visage dominant le monde
car une autre conclusion un peu plus
discrète de ces découvertes que nous
allons voir ensemble c'est qu'il était
en revanche possible de fabriquer du
diamant c'est cette histoire
multicellulaire que nous allons
décrypter aujourd'hui non pas en
compagnie du gotravers j'espère que vous
allez bien mais de Valentine de la
chaîne sciences de comptoir salut c'est
Valentine j'espère que vous allez bien
premier spoil cette fois on va vraiment
réussir à en faire du diamant et
deuxième spoil comme dans le Voyage de
Chihiro rien ne va se passer comme prévu
je suis assis des vous regardez sorti
d'usine bienvenue dans ce deuxième
épisode sur l'industrie du diamant
[Musique]
Lavoisier c'est donc un personnage
majeur de l'histoire de la chimie mais
plus généralement de l'histoire des
sciences et de la méthode scientifique
né en 1743 dans un milieu bourgeois
Antoine de son prénom fait ses premiers
pas dans un 18e siècle tumultueux ou la
révolution de mécaniste dans finit plus
de bouleverser les connaissances
humaines ce grand mouvement de penser
qui s'étale de Copernic à Newton en
passant par Descartes base tout son
raisonnement sur le principe de
causalité la causalité c'est le fait de
supposer que la cause précède l'effet ce
qui peut paraître évident aujourd'hui
mais n’était pas forcément aussi bien
formalisé dans les sciences auparavant
c'est cette approche de la causalité qui
va en étant appliquer à la mécanique
puis à la médecine la biologie permettre
de formidable avancées des connaissances
humaines car désormais peu importe les
phénomènes observés on cherche à
expliquer le réel non pas avec de la
magie ou des liens avec le divin mais
avec des principes simples permettant de
prévoir ou du moins de comprendre chaque
effet à partir de ces causes cette
révolution scientifique qu'on appelle
également la révolution copernicienne
elle ne sait pas faite en un jour
d'ailleurs comme on l'a dit en trop si
Newton on a été un des plus grands
contributeurs par ces travaux sur la
gravité et la mécanique terrestre il
avait d'abord une inclination prononcée
pour les forces occultes et la magie
d'après les écrits retrouvés de ces
travaux le pélo cherchait à fabriquer la
pierre philosophale et l’élixir de vie
pas très sérieux tout ça c'est ce qui
fera d'ailleurs dire à Keynes au Trice
centenaire de la naissance de l'illustre
britannique que Newton n'était pas le
premier de l'âge de la raison mais le
dernier des magiciens en réalité il faut
pas prendre Newton pour un idiot on est
dans une période extrêmement riche où
chacun y va de ses petites
expérimentations de ces petites
réflexions afin de distinguer ce qui
relève de la science du concret du
démontré de ce qui provient plutôt de la
culture chrétienne des superstitions des
croyances et des pseudosciences là où
Newton s'est concentré sur les
mécaniques newtoniennes puisqu'il lui a
donné son nom pour faire simple c'est la
mécanique des gros objets les planètes
ou les pommes qui tombent Lavoisier lui
va plutôt appliquer la méthode
scientifique à l'alchimie un domaine
encore dominé par les croyances et le
rêve de pouvoir fabriquer de l'or ça
marotte à Lavoisier ça va être de
prendre des petits bouts de trucs et de
les casser en d'autres petits bouts de
trucs afin de comprendre de quoi la
matière est prendre des petits bouts de
trucs et puis les assembler ensemble et
écouter le résultat tranquille dans sa
chambre son expérience la plus célèbre
sera la décomposition de l'eau H2O en
hydrogène et en oxygène prouvant ainsi
que l'eau n’était pas un élément à part
entière mais bien un composé une
molécule rassemblant 3 atomes encore une
fois au 21e siècle ça paraît couillon
comme résultat mais à l'époque c'est
juste monstrueux comme conclusion et les
implications sont énormes si l'eau
elle-même n'est pas un élément unique
mais un composé qu'en plus on est
capable de la casser puis de la
reconstruire en conservant à tout
instant les masses avant et après alors
à peu près tout ce qu'on théorisait en
alchimie était juste complètement faux
les conclusions tirées par Lavoisier de
cette démonstration de la transformation
de la matière lui vaudront cette fameuse
citation légèrement apocryphe rien ne se
perd rien de secret tous se transforme
apocryphe puisqu'il ne leur a jamais
vraiment écrite tel quel Antoine qui ne
boude pas son plaisir va réitérer
l'expérience avec un grand nombre de gaz
de solides et de liquides connus de
l'homme afin d'en identifier la nature
moléculaire et notamment vous vous en
doutez puisqu'on parle de ça dans cet
épisode mais il va s'attaquer à notre
fameux diamant ouais on se refait pas ce
qu'on peut définitivement pas
transformer le plomb au nord puisqu'ils
sont faits de corps des atomes quoi
complètement différents il faut bien que
la science qui passe son temps à briser
nos rêves nous permettent quand même de
faire de la maille en 1773 il publie
l'étude sur la destruction du diamant
par le feu où il rencontre de nombreuses
expériences menées ou des diamants sont
exposés à de très fortes flammes ou à
des lumières intenses concentrées avec
des lentilles un peu comme les enfants
qui brûlent des fourmis avec des loupes
je sais pas s'il y a des gens qui font
ça dans la vraie vie j'ai vu ça dans des
dessins animés quand j'étais jeune mais
j'ai jamais vu en vrai donc on s'en bat
les couilles le diamant chauffe devient
rouge puis disparaît forcément vu la
réputation quel diamant à cette période
de l'histoire la pierre éternelle la
dureté extrême c'est publications qui
rapportent la volatilisation d'un
diamant simplement avec de la lumière
font sensation c'est pourtant quelque
chose qu'on avait déjà repéré depuis un
moment cette drôle de disparition du
diamant dans certaines conditions sans
qu'on sache vraiment expliquer pourquoi
et où le caillou se faisait ainsi la
malle Lavoisier mène alors des dizaines
d'expériences dans des conditions
diverses et variées et publie deux
mémoires sur le sujet il a bien observé
expérimentalement qu’après disparition
du diamant on mesure une baisse du
niveau d'oxygène dans la cuve de test et
que dans des conditions où l'on
retirerait préalablement cette oxygène
de l'environnement le diamant brûlé se
transforme en une matière que Lavoisier
décrit comme noir et charbonneuse dans
ces expériences il y a une sacrée
quantité de diamants qui est passée je
peux vous dire qu'ils avaient du budget
les Lavoisier et l'Académie des sciences
mais c'est pas très étonnant puisqu'il
venait d'une famille comme on l'a dit
très fortunée et qu'il a occupé de au
poste de oppose et qu'il a occupé de au
poste de fonctionnaires pendant toute sa
vie il a par exemple travaillé à la
commission des finances mais sûrement
qui voulait changer le système de
l'Intérieur malheureusement c'est ce
statut d'élite aristocratique qui lui
vaudra en 1793 alors que la Révolution
française se part des atours de la
terreur d'être arrêté et condamné à mort
le scientifique supplie demande un
sursis afin de réaliser une dernière
expérience mais ça lui a refusé la
République n'a pas besoin de savoir lui
reste cinglé le président du tribunal
populaire c'est là la fin de Lavoisier
lui je vais prendre des corps et les
découper en plus petits morceaux cette
fois c'est bien sa tête qui sera
détachée de son corps par une bonne
guillotine AOP à la française sans que
le fondateur de la chimie moderne ait pu
percer à jour le secret du diamant
ossoya les aristocrates la lanterne car
contrairement aux croyances populaires
qui ont retenu l'illustre sans tête
comme des coureurs du carbone et de la
véritable nature du diamant c'est en
réalité un de ses homologues qui eu le
bon sens de faire copain copain avec les
révolutionnaires et su ainsi garder la
tête sur les épaules qui apportera le
fin mot à cette histoire Louis Bernard
Guitton de morvault dit guython-morvaux
ouais la particule c'était plus très à
la mode un minéralogiste caoutologue de
l'École polytechnique et député de
Côte-d'Or et députés de Haute-Loire et
députés de Haute-Loire ta gueule sale
c'est à moi que vous parlez là pour vous
je dis ce que j'entends sur les travaux
de Lavoisier affirme que puisque la
combustion d'un diamant produit du gaz
carbonique et que la masse de CO2
produite est égale à la masse d'oxygène
disparue dans l'air ainsi qu'à la
matière du diamant consommé par la
combustion il n'y aurait pas moyen de se
refuser la conséquence que le diamant et
le carbone sont deux êtres identiques et
ouais juste avant d'avoir la tête sur le
bio la voisine est toutes les cartes en
main pour deviner que le diamant le
charbon et le graphite était en fait
composé du même élément et c'est
peut-être même la réputation incroyable
du diamant qu'il empêchait d'aller au
bout de sa pensée et de formaliser
l'existence de ce fameux carbone mot qui
est d'ailleurs utilisé pour la première
fois de l'histoire dans la bouche de
Guiton morvaux ouais le mot carbone qui
en ce moment sur toutes les bouches il a
été inventé par un député dijonnais pour
mettre plus de précision dans la
dénomination de ce radical en le
distinguant du charbon dans l’acception
vulgaire en l'isolant par la pensée de
la petite portion étrangère qui
constitue la cendre nous lui adaptons
l'expression modifier de carbone qui
indiquera le principe essentielle du
charbon la voilà enfin notre réponse au
final le diamant l'objet de toutes les
passions ce n'est que du carbone le
constituant élémentaire de la vie
organique mais également la vulgaire
matière qu'on met dans nos crayons de
bois c'est exactement la même chose par
contre on dit crayon gris exactement la
même chose ou presque parce que c'est
pas la même structure c'est un peu comme
avec les LEGO avec une même brique de
base on peut construire plein de choses
différentes sauf qu'en chimie on peut
pas vraiment bâtir n'importe quoi comme
on veut la matière obéit à des lois pour
mieux comprendre il faut qu'on observe
d'un peu plus près un atome de carbone
le carbone est étravalent ça veut dire
qu'il peut partager quatre électrons
avec ses copains atomes et il peut le
faire de plusieurs manières sous la
forme d'une pyramide ou tétraèdre avec
un angle de 109 degrés et 28 minutes
sous une forme plane en 2D avec deux
liaisons simples et une liaison double
ça veut dire qu'il partage un électron
avec un copain un autre électron avec un
autre copain et deux électrons avec un
troisième copain le tout a des angles de
120 degrés mais il peut aussi avoir une
forme de ligne en partageant deux
électrons avec chacun de ces deux
copains ou bien un électron avec un
copain et 3 avec un autre vous voyez
qu'avec ça les molécules qui contiennent
du carbone peuvent prendre plein de
formes variées et ce même quand on
assemble uniquement des atomes de
carbone entre eux et voilà comment on
peut obtenir aussi bien du graphite que
du diamant le graphite a une forme
dérivée du robothèdre oui ça existe
c'est un parallélépipède qui serait
passé sous un camion mais le plus
souvent la forme du graphite est dérivé
d'un hexagone donc si j'ai bien tout
compris on est dans cette configurations
moléculaire avec des angles de 120
degrés entre chaque copain ces hexagones
sont superposés les uns aux autres c'est
des feuillets microscopiques qui
s'empilent comme une pile de feuilles de
papier avec un espace entre chacune on
est à l'échelle du milliardième de
millimètres mais l'espace est quand même
deux fois plus grand que l'épaisseur des
feuillets donc c'est comme si nos
feuilles de papier les vit avec un
espace d'un demi millimètre entre
chacune on appelle ça un assemblage
lamellaire et quand vous dessinez avec
un crayon gris et on dit vraiment crayon
de bois que vous laissez sur le papier
alors qu'au contraire le diamant a une
structure cubique au niveau moléculaire
quand on chauffe et qu'on comprime du
graphite comme par exemple quand notre
carbone est carrément sous la
lithosphère terrestre les atomes de
carbone se réarrangent à l'intérieur de
la structure cristalline pour former des
tétraèdre et si le diamant et le minéral
le plus dur qu'on connaisse c'est parce
que contrairement au gouvernement il a
une grande cohésion dans sa structure
toutes ces liaisons tétraédriques sont
très fortes et aussi que l'énergie de
liaison entre les atomes est très élevé
ça veut dire qu'il faut fournir
énormément d'énergie si on veut pouvoir
briser tout ça un peu comme si on
voulait séparer des aimants très très
puissants faudrait fournir beaucoup
d'énergie et ça c'est pas évident à
recréer en laboratoire ce qu'on voit là
c'est le diagramme de phase du carbone
ça nous dit quelle forme apparaît selon
comment on comprime en ordonnée et on
chauffe en abscisse l'échantillon on
voit qu'à basse pression on a beau
monter la température notre carbone
restera du graphite il faut le comprimer
à parfois plus de 100000 bars 100000
fois la pression atmosphérique pour
commencer à avoir du diamant donc si on
veut fabriquer du diamant à partir du
charbon la question ça va être d'obtenir
ces hautes pression et c'est pas de la
tarte car c'est du diamant
maintenant qu'on sait qu'on peut
fabriquer une pierre précieuse qu'ils
ont à 200 millions de dollars le kilo à
partir de graphite qui lui ne vaut que
100 dollars le kilo on imagine bien le
business qu'il y a à se faire d'autant
qu'au début du XIXe siècle on est en
plein milieu de la révolution
industrielle et qu'on se réjouit chaque
jour que Descartes fait des avancées
permissent par la science c'est donc une
ribambelle de chercheurs qui sont dans
les starting blocks afin de découvrir la
recette qui permettra de fabriquer du
diamant de synthèse et parmi eux un
jeune étudiant américain descendant des
très pieux pionniers de l'État de l'Utah
l'état Mormon des États-Unis d'Amérique
Howard Tracy Ward Tracy all et
figurez-vous que Tracy all la synthèse
du diamant il va y arriver pour de vrai
mes mains se mirent à trembler les
battements de mon cœur s'accélèrent
tandis que mes genoux ça fait ça et
semblait ne plus pouvoir soutenir mon
propre poids mes yeux venaient d'être
éblouis par les reflets scintillants de
douzaines de minuscules cristaux et à
cet instant je savais qu'enfant des
diamants venaient des trucs créés par
l'homme c'est dans la ville d'ogdan que
naquitra ici
et c'est trop bizarre mais le mec est né
à oakden et une des sources que j'ai
utilisé dans le premier épisode pour
notamment tout ce qui est histoire du
diamant et des gemmes il s'appelle Jack
Oden hogglone est une ville du nord de
l'Utah le seul État d'Amérique du Nord
ou la majorité de la population fait
partie de l'église de Jésus-Christ
dessin des derniers jours autrement dit
de la communauté des Mormons et
pionniers mormons se sont installés dans
cet état désertique au milieu du 19e
siècle fuyant les persécutions des
chrétiens plus traditionnelles on va
dire chrétiens qui n'aimait pas trop les
croyances bizarres de ces gens qui
pratiquent la polygamie ne boivent pas
d'alcool et croient en la parole d'un
prophète nommé Mormon original qui
aurait vécu d'après eux au quatrième
siècle en Amérique du Nord avec toute
une civilisation venue du Moyen-Orient
en bateau Jésus-Christ serait carrément
passé leur faire un petit coucou après
sa résurrection et mormons aurait donc
tenu à raconter tout ça dans un bouquin
avant de l'enterrer sous une colline
dans l'État de New York et 16 bouquins
que Joseph Smith le fondateur de
l'Église affirme avoir déterré plus de
1500 ans après bon c'est donc dans ce
contexte très religieux que se déroule
l'enfant de Howard Tracy all descendant
direct des premiers pionniers que tout
le monde appelle Tracy l'éducation
religieuse de Hall n'est cependant pas
incompatible avec la science pour
laquelle Howard a une passion dès le
plus jeune âge Tracy à deux héros
Jésus-Christ bien sûr mais également
Thomas Edison à qui il vous une
admiration sans borne on a un peu parlé
d'Edison dans cet épisode si ça vous
intéresse quant à l'école primaire ses
camarades explique vouloir devenir
cowboy et astronaute ou Youtube désolé
pour l'anachronisme Tracy clame déjà
haut et fort son rêve de travailler à
General Electric l'entreprise fondée par
Edison et oui je suis d'accord avec vous
ça devait être un gamin super chiant
après un master décroché en 1943 à
l'université de Salt Lake City tra fait
un petit tour à la Navy évidemment
puisque c'est la guerre avant de revenir
en Uta pour réaliser son doctorat de
chimie physique et non pas de
physique-chimie la chimie physique c'est
une discipline où on essaye de mieux
comprendre la Chimie la cuisine ou la
tambouille à l'aide de la rigueur des
connaissances des pratiques de la
physique grosso modo on essaie de rendre
la chimie un peu moins bullshit bref
quelques années après et sa thèse en
poche Tracy all va réussir à rejoindre
les rangs de General Electric et
intégrer une équipe de chercheurs de
l'État de New York pour travailler sur
un projet super secret intitulé ça peut
pressure super pression le projet super
pressure est issu d'une collaboration
débutée en 1941 entre General Electric
et le professeur Bridgeman un
spécialiste de la physique des hautes
pressions professeurs à l'université de
Harvard et lauréat du Nobel de physique
pour ses inventions d'appareils capables
de générer de très hautes pression bref
un CV long comme le bras les machines
développées par Bridgeman dont la plus
aboutie est appelée l'enclume de
Bridgeman consiste à écraser un
échantillon piégé dans un anneau entre 2
gigantesques enclume en carbure de
tungstène au cobalt un des matériaux les
plus résistants au monde petite
subtilité l'anneau qui sert de piège est
fabriqué en une matière spéciale la
4linite une sorte d'argile que les
Amérindiens utilisaient pour faire des
calumets mais qui a surtout la propriété
surprenante d'adhérer tout à fait aux
incluses et de former un joint
complètement étanche qui ne se déforme
plus avec la pression les deux enclumes
actionnées par un système hydraulique
concentre chacune toute la force qu'elle
subisse sur la surface de leurs deux
cônes respectifs qui viennent alors
comprimer les champignons piégés en
exerçant de chaque côté une pression
phénoménale ce qui permet d'atteindre
des niveaux de pression au niveau de
l'échantillon de plus de 400000 bars
soit environ 400000 fois la pression
atmosphérique ces pression elle devrait
être suffisantes pour générer du diamant
on le voit sur notre graphique mais le
souci c'est qu'on a aussi besoin
d'emmener l'échantillon à des
températures de plus de 3000 degrés
Celsius et qu'à ses températures
l'enclume de Bridgeman elle fonctionne
beaucoup moins bien on atteint plus que
des pressions de 35000 bars soit plus de
100 fois moins et comme Valentine l'a
expliqué on a des objectifs de pression
et de température à atteindre il reste
donc pas mal de progrès à faire cette
collaboration est de toute manière
interrompue par la guerre la même que
celle ou Tracy allait parti à dans la
Navy et il faudra attendre 1951 pour que
General Electric relance les travaux ce
peuple show avec une équipe de choc
parmi laquelle Howard Tracy all et quand
Tracy va rentrer dans le labo la
pression va monter d'un cran
il faut dire qu'avant l'arrivée de Tracy
les chercheurs de la nouvelle équipe
avaient quand même fait quelques progrès
dans les très haute température dont on
a parlé ils avaient notamment réussi à
nez le graphite après de 70 000 bars
c'était mieux mais c'est toujours pas
suffisant jusqu'ici il s'était contenté
d'améliorer d'optimiser l'enclume de
Bridgeman sans vraiment proposer de
nouveaux concepts on avait gardé la même
structure qui était simplement améliorée
à la marche dès son arrivée on le va
donc prendre les choses en main et
proposer des design originaux qui vont
permettre d'obtenir des pressions de
plus en plus élevées jusqu'à la
trouvaille qui allait propulser
l'industrie du diamant dans une nouvelle
ère la ceinture de Hall avant que je
vous explique comment fonctionner
l'invention de notre héros du jour il
paraît intéressant de noter de voir
comment le petit chimiste de l'Utah
était traité à New York on le raconte
qu'il devait travailler avec des vieux
pistons hydrauliques qui étaient de si
mauvaise qualité que tout son
laboratoire était inondé et qu'il est
obligé d'aller travailler avec des
bottes en caoutchouc lorsqu'ils l'idée
de la fameuse ceinture générale Electric
le refusa même de lui donner 1000
dollars afin qu'il puisse acheter les
composants d'ailleurs il lui interdire
même de le fabriquer dans les ateliers
ce qui oblige à travailler ici à obtenir
les pièces de manière détournée elle les
assembler un peu en douce quoi après
l'histoire n'explique pas bien le mépris
de General Electric pour les idées de
Tracy surtout que sur le papier le
projet il a l'air prometteur la
principale source de ces informations
étant Tracy au lui-même on peut les
prendre avec des pincettes d'autant que
vu ce qui va se passer on peut
comprendre qu'il est pris le mégaphone
son invention la ceinture de rôle
reprend en effet le concept initial de
l'enclume de Bridgeman on utilise un
échantillon de graphite piégé dans un
joint d'étanchéité qu'on va venir
écraser très très fort pour en faire
monter la pression en fait hall reprend
la plupart des principes éprouvés par
Bridgeman on les améliorant le joint est
désormais fait en pyrophilite qui adhère
encore plus et la forme des encluses est
encore plus conique ce qui permet de
faire un anneau d'étanchéité contenant
plus de graphites et de concentrer
encore plus la zone de pression
mais la véritable innovation c'est
surtout d'un nouveau morceau dont la
ceinture de old tire son nom rôle
rajoute en effet au dispositif un anneau
de cobalt tungstène qui va venir
encercler le joint de pyrophilite
l'anneau en empêchant le jaune de se
déformer vient augmenter encore la
pression subie par le graphique qui peut
désormais atteindre les deux cent mille
barres sans contrainte de température ne
reste plus qu'à faire chauffer
l'échantillon ce que l'équipe réalise
ingénieusement en faisant circuler un
puissant courant électrique à travers
les enclumes et puis un jour ça y est le
16 décembre 1954 Tracy all rouvre sa
presse et croix s’évanouir il n'est pas
sûr de croire ce qu'il a sous les yeux
c'est à dire ce pourquoi des générations
David se sont battues des alchimistes
médiévaux jusqu'au plus obstiné des
chercheurs modernes pour la première
fois de l'histoire de l'humanité plus de
150 ans après la décapitation de
Lavoisier des diamants viennent d'être
fabriqués en laboratoire l'expérience
est ensuite répliquée avec tout un tas
de matériaux de base plus ou moins
fantaisistes comme du sucre oui
apparemment du sucre ça marche parce que
bah c'est organique donc c'est fait avec
du carbone donc tu peux fabriquer du
diamant avec et General Electric se met
évidemment à déposer des dizaines de
brevets autour de ses recherches qu'elle
a plus ou moins financée et la
production commerciale de diamant
commence dès 1957 vous imaginez
peut-être alors que le docteur hall est
devenu immédiatement le self-men MAN
qu'il méritait désormais d'être
continuant ses travaux chez General
Electric après que la direction navré
d'avoir ignoré ces idées de génie et
présenter son mea culpa et lui accorder
un poste prestigieux et non la réalité
est bien plus amer vous allez voir c'est
miskine pour le remercier de sa
trouvaille General Electric lui offrit
un bon d'achat d'une valeur de 10
dollars et 10 dollars c'est une sacrée
somme moi noël j'avais une orange vous
comprendrez donc que Tracy Holl et
démissionné dès 1955 seulement quelques
mois après sa découverte trop humilié
par cette affront se réorientant
professionnellement all rejoindra le
monde académique à l'Université de
Provost où il finira quand même
directeur de la recherche évidemment on
se demande pourquoi il n'aurait pas
continué ses travaux mais pour ajouter
l'insulte à l'injure il se trouve que
c'est bien général électrique
l'entreprise Edison qui est propriétaire
des brevets de la ceinture de Hall et
ouais c'est comme ça que ça marche il
était salarié j'ai envie de dire vu le
connard qui était Edison étant donné
toutes les inventions et les brevets qui
leur a volé cadeau de chercheurs si
c'est ton héros d'enfance tu as un petit
peu mérité de te faire baiser comme ça
par l'entreprise qui l'a fondé allez
heureusement pour lui trahiss you n'a
pas tout à fait dit son dernier mot et
il en manquera même une nouvelle presse
encore plus performante et qui surtout
contourne les brevets déposés par
General Electric sur sa propre invention
la presse Tetra et drague bon on va pas
repasser du temps à expliquer comment ça
fonctionne je pense que vous avez
compris le concept général on écrase un
échantillon graphite dans un joint
d'étanchéité pyramidal mais cette fois
non pas entre deux enclus mais entre 4
enclume encore aujourd'hui c'est ce
principe technologique et ses
descendants qui sont principalement
utilisés dans l'industrie et dans la
recherche sur les hauts de pressions
cool refondra même une entreprise de
diamant de synthèse et les gamins
intitulée mega Diamonds qui existent
encore aujourd'hui même si elle n'a pas
vraiment eu le succès escompté et que
son manager Benji est apparemment
quelqu'un de très désagréable après
avoir passé quelques années à faire le
missionnaire avec sa femme au Zimbabwe
et par là j'entends faire le
missionnaire Mormon faire du
prosélytisme Tracy all finira sa vie
dans une ferme avec des vergers en Utah
sans jamais connaître la fortune ni
recevoir de prix Nobel avec toujours au
fond de la bouche le goût désagréable et
amer du manque de reconnaissance et de
l'invention volée je pourrais conclure
en vous disant que le fait qu'une
entreprise privée qui vous salarie
s'approprie le fruit de votre travail
intellectuel né fondamentalement pas
différent de l'appropriation de la force
de travail par le capital mais c'est un
vaste sujet et c'est pas trop ce qu'on a
traité aujourd'hui même si ce serait
sûrement intéressant d'en parler une
autre fois je pourrais aussi vous
raconter que si ça se trouve Tracy ou
n'est même pas le premier à avoir
vraiment inventé les diamants puisqu'à
posteriori une entreprise suédoise a dit
qu'elle avait réussi en fabriquer avant
lui mais que juste il avait décidé de
pas le dire hall ne sera ainsi plus le
génie qui a inventé les diamants de
synthèse mais simplement le premier à
l'avoir dit publiquement mais déjà c'est
pas très intéressant ça change pas le
fond de ce qu'on a dit et en plus c'est
impossible de confirmer ces informations
non la manière dont je veux conclure
c'est en parlant des conséquences de
cette invention on l'a vu dans le
premier épisode les diamants sont chers
parce qu'ils sont historiquement rares
et très demandés qui constituent des
liens de prestige du fait de leur rareté
et de l'image d'éternité qu'il véhicule
la logique de la loi du marché du
fonctionnement même de l'offre et de la
demande je voudrais donc dire que
l'invention d'une technique de
fabrication relativement moins coûteuse
pour un potentiel de production infini
puisqu'on a dit qu'on pouvait fabriquer
du diamant même avec du sucre conduisent
à ce que le prix du diamant s'effondre
complètement parce que oui malgré ce que
certains vont pouvoir dire le diamant
qu'on fabrique en laboratoire c'est
exactement le même que celui qu'on
récupère dans les mines en Inde en
Afrique du Sud ou Brésil donc selon la
théorie puisqu'en même bien a sur un
même marché un prix unique défini par
l'offre et la demande on aurait dû voir
le prix du diamant s'effondrer jusqu'à
rejoindre petit à petit les coûts du
diamant synthétique le diamant naturel
devrait avoir le même prix que le
diamant synthétique et le prix du
diamant minet devrait tendre vers celui
du diamant fabriqué bah ouais parce que
dans ce cas le diamant il n'est plus
vraiment rare et si on boucle avec notre
introduction là sur le Voyage de Chihiro
le personnage du sans visage et ses
petites pépites d'or c'est exactement ce
qui va se passer à un moment du film les
pépites d'or que le sans visage ne
distribue à tour de bras elles sont
devenues tellement abondantes que les
différents protagonistes des bains
thermaux ils vont commencer à se
questionner sur leur valeur si on a
autant que ça qu'on peut créer à
l'infini est-ce que vraiment c'est une
richesse dans le film se doute va
bientôt être matérialisé par la
dégradation elle-même des pépites d'or
qui se transforment en poussière sous
les yeux horrifiés des personnages la
perte du statut précieux conséquence de
l’abondance s'incarne métaphoriquement
dans cette corruption physique ouais
cette phrase elle sert à rien j'avais
juste envie d'écrire un truc stylé ouais
c'est un peu une chaîne non Théo ici à
moins que vous viviez dans une grotte ou
dans une mine de diamant vous aurez
sûrement constaté que les diamants c'est
toujours très cher on continue dans
monter sur des boucles d'oreilles sur
des bagues en or et c'est toujours censé
être le truc le plus précieux qu'on
offre pour les mariages bref rien ne
s'est passé comme prévu parce que nos
chimistes et nos ingénieurs de General
Electric ils sont bien sympas mais ils
ont pas compris qu'en phase 2 ils
avaient aussi une industrie implantée
depuis des siècles et particulièrement
riches qui n'avaient certainement pas
l'intention de se laisser faire et ça
c'est pas moi qui le dis c'est Oussama
Amar pourquoi les diamants c'est cher
qui pensent que les diamants sont rares
levez la main évidemment que tout le
monde pense que le diamant est rare en
fait le diamant est une arnaque faut
savoir que le prix réel d'offre de
diamant devrait être 200 fois inférieur
à ce qu'il est comme ils ont 100% de
l'approvisionnement et que les 20% qui
ne maîtrisent pas ils ont des accords
avec ces gens là aussi ils ont cornisé
le marché du diamant bon je vous rassure
à défaut d'avoir le charisme d'Oussama
on va traiter le sujet avec un peu plus
de rigueur avec un peu plus de
profondeur et un angle qui je pense vous
surprendra mais ça ce sera pour la
troisième et dernière partie de cette
série sur l'industrie du diamant dans
cette deuxième partie on a beaucoup
parlé d'histoire des sciences et de
techniques mais dans la troisième partie
on va rentrer dans le dur et on abordera
notamment l'aspect économique du cours
du diamant et l'intense lobbying qui
entoure ce milieu bien entendu ce serait
dommage de la rater alors abonne-toi et
active la cloche comme ça elle passera
pas sous les radars on contourne
l'algodes recommandation et surtout bah
ça me fait grave plaisir pour encore
plus de kiffes Legends lâcher un like et
surtout un commentaire je le dis à
chaque fois mais ce qui me fait le plus
plaisir c'est de lire les retours quand
la vidéo est sorte tenez évidemment à
remercier Valentine encore une fois pour
sa présence sur cet épisode puis pour
finir je vous remercie vous qui êtes
toujours là qui qui me motivait à faire
des recherches et à partager ça ensemble
franchement je crois que c'est difficile
d'imaginer un autre hobby qui
m'enrichira autant et me pousserait
autant à réfléchir à des sujets donc
j'espère que je vais pouvoir continuer à
le faire mon temps sur ce
repassez bien vos colles de chemise
arrêtez d'utiliser des cotons-tiges
c'était Alcide pour sortir du livre le
god Allemagne